all right awesome Senators brilliance
comes around all that Southeast LA in
Whittier Norwalk were the only
neighborhood in two cities we take up a
section of Whittier and Santa Fe Springs
so we're the only gang you know in South
East LA that occupies two cities yeah
will be again came out in a 1941 but we
should be called flood ranch but they
changed name because there was a lot of
frogs right there by the river bottom so
they changed us to own country miles
which in English means singing frogs and
in my hood you couldn't be from my
neighborhood unless you had family
members maybe your brother or sister
your daddy or mom if you didn't have
nobody no kind of family members in the
hood you couldn't get in and that lasted
till about 89 after that when a little
bit of a different different way
different uh somebody created in action
you know and they we did was uh we got
Adam we let him know he wanted to get in
the hood so bad but he couldn't get in
cuz he they have no family members so
one of the guys to go out there okay
well bring those two bodies and you can
get in or he didn't bring two he brought
five in one weekend you know so we let a
man you know so he broke that tradition
you know that's my homie today right now
he's in Pelican Bay he's doing like
about eighty years but that's he broke
the tradition you know so that tradition
was broken me I don't really I didn't
really agree with it due to the fact
that you know I feel that if you know
somebody for a long time since a grammar
school they're most likely not to tell
on you nowadays that you get people from
other cities and stuff there's no type
of uh there's no type of uh yeah loyalty
or you know a commonality there you know
but uh I've been from my neighborhood
since the age of thirteen I've had my
teardrop that was the first tattoo I got
I got it at 15 years old
well you know it didn't represent that I
had been in prison for a few years
because I was only 15 and I wanted to
fill the insole it really represents
when you do the deed you know in other
words you take care of business you put
somebody in the dirt you know
so I earned my turn job back 15 and
resolvers and it's been on my face since
then I was gonna remove it but my little
girl she's from my neighborhood she's my
homegirl she told me not that if I
removed it wouldn't be me you know so I
left it on my face you know I went to
prison did 17 years but I've been to
juvenile all ye I've been to a placement
juvenile camp three times and I went to
prison first time for uh two counts of
kidnap and I was picked off for three
counts of murder into four counts of
kidnap the ended up convicted me of two
counts of kidnap to give me 15 years I
did a seven out of that got out for a
year went back and did seven more
straight got out and then went back in
there for more right now I just barely
got a parole so right now I'm doing
alright you know but yeah I've been I've
been out for about two years now but
I've been to the county here and there
you know but the longest I've been was
seven years straight that gave me seven
years lady percent for a 20 sack of
crystal meth they gave me seven years
for that yeah they were trying to strike
me out trying to give me a 25 of life
for a 20 bag of glass I ended have to
take a deal for six years seven years
and 80% I did every seven I did over
till the last day I was in there getting
high I was in there stabbing people you
know went to the shoe program and then
that's when I got affiliated you know
they are they took me a second mother
took me pack sent a packet to Sacramento
to see if they could uh you know the
works all placed me with these gentlemen
and uh I didn't have no photos with
anybody in it and have no letters I
didn't have no identifying marks one
thing
I never got any type of marks except
this one where you know it affiliated me
you know where they can see my body and
say well that taxi right there means
something you know all my tattoos man
something I got my daughters names my
wife's name and my frogs yeah I wanted
to earn my frogs you know I got seven
total you know in my hood you had to
earn them if you didn't earn them
then we would take you out ourselves one
of my little homie ended up getting five
frogs on him he didn't earn him so they
killed him like a week later yeah
represents a soul so many soul yeah so
when he stole you can put it on your
body yeah one of my homies didn't earn
it so they killed him my other homie got
earned he had a triple murder he put
three frogs on on this guy put five so
the guy had three killed the guy was
fired because he never earned him mainly
I was the one that used to find people
that couldn't get [ __ ] he couldn't eat
fine you know I used to go undercover
I've had my hair red I've had my hair
blond
I mean I've shaved my moustache off more
glasses I grew my hair long shaved my
head I used to change my identity a lot
yes he found getting caught my buddy FBI
for a while yeah yeah that was on me for
a while they were on me for about maybe
about total they were robbing for about
ten years due to the fact that I had
five family members that were those guys
yeah yeah that guy should cover up my
tattoos with makeup you know I just do a
lot of things you know sometimes I have
my mustache trimmer a little small or
I'll let my goatee in my chest and I'll
shave it roh-roh
thin you know I mean you know sometimes
upward glasses I like that red hair
before yeah I had red hair before they
were looking for me for uh they're
looking for me for a double-murder and I
changed my hair to read but they ended
up busting my homeys
mium had the same first name let's doing
this gang well you know out here there's
more room to get around there's more
things you can do and get away with
because you can duck and hide and
maneuver in prison you ain't going
nowhere
you can't hide you can't duck you know
you got to face everything head-on the
way I learned that best is if you did it
you did it you know there's one thing I
did they asked me to stab somebody I
ended up stabbing him and then the other
guy asked me why did you stab him so I
felt it was the right thing to do you
know but I was the type of person if I
did something wrong more than stab me
you know and due to the fact that I
carried myself in a certain level while
my punishment was severe my pushing my
punishment wasn't do 50 pushups or do
113 burpees my punishment was they would
get a knife and maybe they would make
the handle they'd make the handle about
five inches long and you got the seven
inch knife so they would leave about
maybe about an inch and a half out and
they would stab you with that and that's
just a checking more or less that's just
don't do that again you know I wouldn't
get a beat down that wouldn't get
regulated yeah because I knew better I
had been in prison there was no excuse
for uh this black dude bought an ice
cream and I went and got his ice cream
and took a bite I know better than that
but if I did take a bite well that my
punishment would be severely you know
I've been stabbed twice just getting
checked you know I mean and each time I
got stabbed about seven times but it was
just because I needed to get checked in
a level that I carried myself on you
know I already been in prison five times
there was no excuse for me more or less
and I'm a strong believer in that I was
from a believer in you get punished and
you get punished in the
in will say at this level because you
carry yourself at this level a lot of
things can be told but you know in a
certain way you know there's an
information I can give you but there's
certain information vital information
that I can't give you you know as in
names places but I can speak things I
did you know in my life you know I mean
and I did it all you know I've I've
heard about things that dudes did in
prison you know like I heard about a guy
that they sent four dudes to stab this
guy and he stabbed them all well when
that came about to me and they sent four
dudes at me I did the same thing I
stabbed all four of them and they were
supposed to come and get me and I end up
stabbing all of them so apparently they
sent the wrong guys to get at me so what
they did was they didn't try it again
you know I mean and that was simply out
of hate F out of you know people just
not liking me you know not liking the
way I did things but I was saying I was
19 years old in prison and I was running
all the Centinela now it's level four
and level three and I was only 19 years
old you know me and I was speaking to
gentlemen that were 4550 been in prison
like 10 15 years and I had more rank
than then for the simple fact was the
way I carried myself you know and you
earn I mean yeah and I went to the
county jail you know and the first time
I went through you know I didn't really
do anything in general I did my time and
got out the second time I went through I
went balls out I stabbed everybody in
anything you know I mean it I've ran
five prisons the whole prison every yard
every dude I was in charge everybody I
very Centinela ironwood chuckwalla to
hatchapee and Delano not talking about
all all five every dude on there I was
responsible for all of them and I was 23
years old 24 years old and there was a
lot of times that do you got into with
the Muslim brothers and they don't
Muslims they don't play especially on
level 4 you know and one of the homies I
left in charge because I went to a
family visit when I came back this dude
just totally disrespected these
individuals and they wanted to take his
win doing that they were life for his
they didn't care they killing this war
so I had to get at the moves move I and
he's an older guy and I said yeah you
know apparently I heard that you wanted
you wanted someone to talk to that was
in charge here he said yeah can you get
him I said yeah I'm that guy you know he
looked at me he's like man how old are
you and I said you know ages but a
number man you know the way I post him
once I said excuse me you know be highly
appreciate if I can get a little bit of
your time and understanding you know and
when I pushed him in that fashion
he was a lot quicker to speak to me you
know and he spoke to me we resolved
everything and I had little homie
removed you know cuz he did disrespect
the man you know but I was 22 years old
at that time you mean and I was already
running a prison so you know when I got
out here and I've ran three cities in
Orange County and I'm from LA so you
know when I had got out of prison the
first time you know they knew of my
reputation when I was a youngster I
earned my bones in the hood by finding
people they couldn't get found in other
words I was the guy that they called
when this guy burned the key one of the
main connections and they wanted him
found I said I used to change my hair
color changed my name my appearance and
everything
well one time we had this girl she was
moving pounds of glass pounds moving
maybe six seven pounds a day and nobody
glasses a crystal meth and nobody could
get close to her so I sat back and I
thought how could close to this woman
you know I mean so what I did was I
wanted to change my appearance I went in
borrowed an ounce of glass that was
powerful it was pure no cutting or
nothing so I got that ounce of glass I
went to this girl's house and knocked on
the door they opened the door I went in
there and I spoke to her you know
introduced myself is somebody totally
different because I knew she was on top
of her game she didn't want nobody to
get close to her the way I got closer
was I went in there I got on the phone
had a fake conversation told this guy a
man said that 15 Jack grand over here
sitting at ten over here so now she's
listening so what I did was I got down
to dope and I threw it on the
and I told her go ahead go ahead and try
that so on the way out the door she's
like hey you forgot your answer dope I
said no that's nothing
I get that constant you can have that so
what I did was I gave it to her really I
pulled that out from somebody but I used
it so that she would see that that was
nothing to me because I wanted to get to
the pounds because that's what she was
dealing at nobody can't get close to her
so I left the pounds area after my
number I know she was gonna get high she
called me about 15 minutes later she
said damn this [ __ ] is pure how can I
get more of it I said it depends on what
you want you know I wanted to get her up
to the pounds due to the fact that she
was only saying she was dealing else's
but I knew she was dealing pounds so she
called me the following day about ten in
the morning
she tells me if I can come over I go
over and I get there and when I get
inside she's sitting with two
individuals now I know these two
individuals have a weapon because I have
a weapon myself well what happens is she
has to use the bathroom so she excuses
herself so at that time it gave me the
opportunity to talk to these two
individuals which these two individuals
were her torpedoes in other words they
were used to protect her
but now I needed to get at them
excluding her so I spoke to them in
Gnawa and whatnot why is it it's the
Aztec language and I knew that these
dudes knew now ah because previously I
knew of one guy his reputation and who
he was so I spoke to him in now uh the
other one didn't know Gnawa so I was I'm
speaking to this guy in Agua the other
guy don't understand what we're talking
about well what I'm really doing is I'm
lacing this guy up and they need to know
who I am who I represent and who I work
for because he's unaware of what I'm
doing I'm letting him know why I'm there
I'm there to take over her business keep
him as a torpedo but yet I'm gonna take
over her business and how I'm gonna do
that is I'm gonna infiltrate on what she
does so if she came back into the room
now I have one her torpedoes on my side
but he's really working for her but now
this is my Inside Man this is how I'm
getting in I didn't use woman I need
nobody I use it an individual that was
protecting her and that was my way in so
what happened when she came out to
shower we talked a little bit now he's
on my team
so what we did was we we got her to do a
deal for five pounds
and what happens well he went to his
Starbucks all we did we were switching
cars
she had one car with all the doping in
and she had another car there were same
color saying Bratton marking everything
so what happened was she ended up giving
the keys to the individual who was
taking care of her but all along he was
working for me he had already got paid
so we're getting her for 5 pounds 5
pounds of glass took her out of business
stepped in her house took over made her
forced to sign the house over to us she
signed her house over she signed her car
matter of fact we even kept her dogs you
know two of her dogs that she had at
home well the [ __ ] got Bhosle after a
while she seen us in her house tick we
always took over business we're dealing
out of her house we're selling women out
of there selling drugs out of there were
selling guns out of there when one day
she comes back she sister and she's
crying on her couch and she had all this
she had pounds a week she had pounds a
dog she had nice cars now she could read
all the way down to zero and the reason
why we got this broad was for the simple
fact that she worked 10 years alone on
she is saying that she took care of my
uncle she never sent him a dollar but
she had his back in because the fact
that once you get so big and you start
dealing pounds or you have a lot of
people that will be on your every
packing call you also have [ __ ]
that'll raise their hand just to kill
this food for an ounce of dope just
because this girl had so much dope when
she had so much dope is so much cloud
around her that once we took all that we
shrink her down to practically nothing
so she went from being way up here to
way down here you know I mean and after
a while she got real bossy real real
mostly so we did was we set her up with
him on the dog she got busted we're like
three pounds of dope and a dirty gun so
she got busted they sent her away for 20
years
she got out about two years ago and we
just let her back in you know cuz I
still do my thing but I do it from a
dish
and snow I'm in charge I'm sitting and
I'm sitting what they call its back line
you know I did everybody go in the front
dealing yet you're calling the shots all
you want yeah you can tell him you're
running everything I don't care you know
I mean it's really me but I always have
a frontman you know like I say to him I
tell my god things I've did work
individuals wouldn't even would even
fathom the idea you know mean of how
this was done like I did something in
three days that seven fools couldn't do
in nineteen months coming out of Pelican
Bay and that was with that girl no one
could get close to her nobody could do
anything but the way I played her was I
got inside with her I got in her
business and then I what I did was I
created an army without her knowing it
so I took everything she had everything
you don't everything all dope or money
I got a Rolex watch out of it a
herringbone chain a brand-new 2005
Nissan Pathfinder just with this no
physical no physical harm came to nobody
it was all mental you know I had to get
get inside her head you know and that
was like one of the best things I did
because it earned me a lot of bones and
earned me a lot of you know a lot of
respect a lot of clout you know I mean
and also my name got changed I used to
be Casper from katanas now they call me
Johnny Caspar because they want to
simplify who they're coming to get
because there's five of us there's five
Casper's but they changed my name to
Johnny Caspar and when you're from a
gang and you've been in prison
you can't change your name because if
you change your name something's wrong
either you're hiding you told on
somebody you just can't be from a gang
and change your name I didn't change my
name they change my name so now they
call me Johnny Caspar JC for short you
know but to be honest with you I'm a
soldier I'm a sold out for the mob I'm a
soldier you know
I've been one for well say 20 years now
I was one since 1993 and I've been in
trouble for stinginess
I've been scolded very very bad verbal
tongue lashing because I felt that
you're supposed to go around and say
this is me this is me look at me no real
soldier stays in the cut ladies back in
the cut when it's time you come out and
handle your business but you shouldn't
put yourself on front and I was a kind
of individual like everybody else I
wanted everybody to see me like the
Teflon Don look at me look at me look
what I'm doing and I wanted that and I
got scolded very very harshly for doing
that you know so now I necessarily don't
do that unless it has to be put out
there and I have to tell it like out
here in all of downtown in Skid Row I'm
the last Mexican individual they'll come
out when something needs to get done
here in all of skilled war and all of
skid row I got I got more juice than
anybody around here I don't say that
boastfully or look at me and know I'm
speaking the real any black individual
you talk to here and you're Mexican
individual when it comes down to the
last man you're gonna talk to I'll be
the last one yeah I'll make the final
shot no not at all no only I can get
myself in trouble you know me yeah yeah
that's no problem you know I'll speak
about free of what I gotta speak about
the baby I have that no I have never
sued a no and I have the right to speak
about things that I did myself you know
I mean things that I've accomplished it
that I've did for the cause for the sued
you know mean for for the mob you know
there were certain things that I did and
like I say out here I'm the last man on
the totem pole when you get to the last
man you once beat a lesson video it's
gonna be me there might be 10 guys in
front but the last guy you're gonna
speak to and get the shot is from me I'm
gonna be the last one that calls a shot
you know whether it's gonna happen or
whether it's not whether this guy gotta
move out of his [ __ ] tent and get off
the street yeah I mean I'm like one of
the only Mexican individuals that could
sling dope anywhere right here really
were we're limited to one to one Street
town I mean I could sling on any street
any corner anywhere I don't there's
certain parts I won't go like won't say
for instance say
percent pedro and san julián right
around six I won't sell a dime bag right
there cuz I know better I know that I'm
not supposed to sell or the exact
innovators are selling I'm limited to
where actually I can sell with me
because I got the respect and
understanding what a lot of these guys
like to sell in any street corner I want
I can move on any Street I want because
of the fact I know what to go through
and who to get at who runs what Street
what game kind of falling through you
know you know they're trying to make wax
right now you know and they're cooking
it in a tent and our two days ago blew
up on them and you got burned all his
legs have his name at a weed they
getting weed and they're draining weed
for the juices nutrients that are in
there it is what it really is it's key
fits the tht that's on there but they
have to boil it at a certain temperature
and you got to use a certain type of gas
you know if you get cheap gas then you
burn your [ __ ] and it takes like gas but
if you get that really expensive gas
then ones you like eighty dollars you
can you know that [ __ ] right there burns
so fine it's so clean that your stuff
comes back clear and it's really clear
the clearer the better you know and I
got 20 wheels cooking it right now but
one of them just bullying self love
[Music]
who's thanking you down was uh
see I got stabbed in my neck oh I got my
throat cut from over the cross I told my
hot dog I could we could try to carjack
me yeah that's right
this was disciplined this one problem
yeah this is discipline this is a no you
know this is saying too much your names
out there too much you know and I did
something that I knew I shouldn't did I
was the guy that did it
he's my best friend today because I felt
that he gave me action remaining real
keeping real because he could've did
much much more but this right here this
is just a checking no no no not at all
mmm this when I got checked this was for
something I did wrong this was my hair I
got carjacked he cut my throat all the
way across dude was behind me he had a
knife to my throat he said I'm taking
your car and I was like you taking [ __ ]
Compton Crips oh yeah yeah yeah by the
top of there at the top of the food
chain
oh yeah the top of the food chain yeah I
walked through these streets by myself
all hours of the night a lot of
individuals tell me why do you do there
why you walked through these certain
streets man will you know that there's
nothing but black zone right so I'm
gonna walk down there regardless you'll
[ __ ] what street it is and I walk any
yard I walk any Street any hood you know
because the fact that I'm not there to
cause any harm if I'm there I mean
they're there to talk to who's running
[ __ ] right there to fix what the [ __ ]
they're doing on there for simple reason
if somebody sees me in their hood and
they know me they know I'm there for a
certain reason I'm there to either talk
to the guys that are in charge or I'm
there to [ __ ] scold them and under
they pick up some cars some weapons as
some money and they're gonna give it up
you know there's times I've walked in
you know you could just say he knew me
he didn't even know me but I sat there
and talk to the guy game
for name and everything and then when I
was tired of talking him I told me no
you're talking to the person you said
you were taken care of
so now he's in trouble took his car he's
gone his money everything I meant to do
this woman out of his house you know
wasn't his wife but it was a girl that
he was being with I took her from him
right there on the spot for the simple
fact that he was stating he was paying
rent or that's taken care of business
and he wasn't giving a penny up you know
and there's a lot of images that do that
you know you might be selling pounds of
dope but when I asked you you tell me
you're selling diamonds and but I
already know your whole business already
infiltrated your business I already
talked to all your clientele took gave
them dope you get people who use dope
you give them dope to tell you anything
they want you just keep on poking
information giving a more adult that's
how you anything you want to know so
every time I approached somebody about a
situation I knew all the outs and ins
the rights and that's the ups and downs
I knew all about their business so I was
asking the questions and see how much
they would lie to me what type of false
information they would give me and a lot
of nine times out of ten they would lie
to me you know I mean and I will find
out their line and I would decide how
much I wanted to you know text them for
you know I've been in the county jail
where I took a dude [ __ ] all the way
down to his toothpaste all the way down
to his toothpaste and had him beat up
three times a day for a whole month
straight you know it's different strokes
run for different folks you know I mean
I've been in so many situations like I
said you know I run my gang my area
prisons yards of tears you know I mean I
did it all and not and not just at a gen
you know 98.9% foods [ __ ] up that run
yards they're no longer any good
they're X&Y now you know the air lock it
up you know I'm 46 years old and I'm
still on the main line
I'm still active oh yeah around here a
lot of people are non active but the way
I do it is I just rolled through and
treating an individual or he treats me
on your [ __ ] he's wanted about a mom
or he's wanted by his hood as long as
his name don't come past me he's cool
you know like I said I'll do this on
yards I used to hit yards and I'd hit
her yard and foods would see me there
and they would start acting funny and
everything finally they get at me and
say man I'm doing this right I'm doing
that right I'm doing this right I'd be
like I don't give a [ __ ] what you're
doing right here yeah but I know you're
here and I know that you know I know
what's up with you you know I know I'm
just letting you know I'm doing
everything right
let's put it like this the only thing
you got to worry about is your kite
comes with my name on the outside and
your name on the inside.thanks the only
thing I worry about other than that
you're cool just remember if a guy comes
and has my name on the outside and your
name on the inside or you're in trouble
a kite is another word so a note you
know they sent you a note dude might get
it write it in the shoe program
whoop it up his ass take it to Delano
pass it off to somebody in turn a no put
his ass brings it to me and it's a note
for me but he came all the way from the
bay and I might be down in Delano it
took maybe two months to get to me but
he got to me though you know and it was
probably transported in for whose asses
you know and but that's how it is you
know I mean it's written maybe on a
piece of paper inside those little
yellow tablets but it has like five
pages in a book that's how small the
writing is some guys can write social
mom I can't believe how small they can
write I can write small as [ __ ] small
real small I could put on I can write
you a hole later on just a wrapper of a
gun your gun wrapper the gum wrapper
just the white piece that big I'd write
I could tell you a whole story on there
just by writing you know yes it's you
you become to be able to write so small
with so small of a pencil and then fold
it small just stick it in my nose that's
that's fall I just make it stick like
four cuts inside my nose all the way
back in my
in my nose cavity and not to proud boast
about the biggest thing I've ever who
was like a nine inch knife you know and
I actually felt that [ __ ] poking right
here yeah I had to sit down on one and
she gave I rolled like this
I actually feel it poking my spine you
know and we're talking about Oh talk
about just picture of banana you know
and today to keister that it's very
[ __ ] hot or difficult there's a
certain way you have to do it or certain
way you got to place your body when you
put it in as you haven't in say I'm
gonna hoop a knife first thing I do is I
wrap in plastic wrapping and plastic
wrap in plastic then I get a hunting
racer from a pencil and I'll stick the
eraser right on the tip then I'll tie
it's so [ __ ] tight that if I gotta
take it out of my ass as soon as I pull
it out my ass all I do is pop the top of
that eraser off all the plastic shoots
back boom and I got nothing but the
blade and I remember once I hit this guy
I have to rewrite that
hoop it again I got a recycle yeah I
mean who but I mean keister it up my ass
yeah yeah and that's the way you
transfer weapons phones dope kites or
say [ __ ] uh
the birthday card the birthday card is a
birthday card is slang for everybody's
information your name your number your
what they call you your hood your court
dates what you're busted for you mean
everything it's all one line is all your
information there might be a hundred
guys on one piece of paper that I have
and I've been to places where I was in
LA killing gang module in 95 96 they'll
give you a piece of paper with 25 names
on it and you have to memorize these
names every [ __ ] name every [ __ ]
hood and you get nice you coupe it and
go to you bit hoop it key straight and
then go to court and you have to
remember every individual that was on
there cuz if one of those anymore just
slip through and you don't get them or
your ass is grass your ass is grass then
on top of that remember you keister that
8-inch knife you come back in you're in
court all day with it in your stomach
and believe me metal is very very heavy
so you actually feel like you gotta take
a [ __ ] all day long but it's just that
the metal so heavy it feels like you got
to use the bathroom first time I made a
mistake I thought I had to take a [ __ ]
hell naw I took that [ __ ] out I didn't
have to use the bathroom
I had to hoop it again so another result
was just rated myself you know to be
honest with you that's what I was doing
I was writing to myself but that was how
I learned you know I learned by
experience you know I mean and you know
when I hope that [ __ ] I had it in there
all day and then you come back from
court from 7:00 in the morning Oh from
4:30 in the morning all the way to 5:30
in the evening I had this knife inside
me now I want to come out so bad but
when we get back from court they
stripped us butt-naked
now they wants you to squat 20 times
like this 20 times then 10 times then 15
times more and now turn around cough all
that then I want to come out bad you
know I mean and then they got 15
individuals and they're just gonna pick
who everybody has an iPhone
but they just pick who they want to pick
they find you with that knife
that's another charge another five years
so you're taking out you're taking a
risk
just taking it but the way that he stood
was if you were from the age of 18 to 35
mandatory you take a weapon mandatory
used to have anybody on that list but if
you're 35 and older you don't have to
take one but if you're from 18 to 35
mandatory you take a weapon but in
certain courthouses Norwalk cords CCB
you know the long beach there was only
certain courthouses that you can take
him to because they want to serve the
individuals hit they want you had to
take it with you all day you're
responsible for that thing you lose it
is your ass you lose it you're gonna get
stabbed you know I mean I mean it was so
so on key in there that I can have a
knife and you can be 77 cells down and
there's noise going on talking to me I
drew up that knife and it would hit one
time [ __ ] and I snatch it within seconds
she would hear shoot a name dude heard
me drop like one time all he did was
just hit the cement once and I snatched
it he heard that little Bing and it's
shoot a name and when you shoot a name I
dropped it by the time I shoot the name
my name these individuals in my cell
they put their shoes on I'm already
knowing what's gonna happen to me I'm
gonna get a full force outside and
that's 39 seconds of getting beat down
at full force kicking everything all
five you're selling they're gonna beat
you up
yeah and you might have been with these
cellmates for [ __ ] three years
fighting your case you know the next day
they might have to kill you you know
I've been where they've been these dudes
been together for us
here's they got drunk they got
disrespectful and yeah and they'd have
to kill this guy in the cell you know
and they did with this dude for three
years you know but you had to kill him
you know and some guys are not just
going out like that
every individual is that I mean you step
up 80 times and they're still standing
up and they're telling you hit him until
he's on the ground he don't want to get
in the ground he's not going down there
was a people Samoan doing it he [ __ ]
wants to hit him 180 times he was not
going to the ground and they wanted him
on the ground and I said hey he's not
going down the road we could sit here
and we can stab him all day he is not
going to the ground and the initial the
initial
they shot the initial Crichton and said
that they wanted him laid out well the
individuals not going down there he's
not laying out I'm here for what we're
doing we're trying to do everything he's
not falling this interval never fell we
never found he stayed up on his feet
must have hit him a hundred eighty times
and that was because he owed 50 dollars
for heroin and they were calling him to
catch the chain to go to the state
before he went to the state he had to
get stabbed and just because he's boss
but that's the chance you take it's a
two-week period I got sentenced I'm
ready to go to prison within those two
weeks I can buy dope but I better hope
that one day don't come up where they
call my name and I owe I owe to buy old
$50 here and $50
okay well reach 50 you're gonna be here
five times you're gonna get stabbed ten
times then you catch a chanting go so
you know just say I hope 350s I'm
getting hit 15 times and the way they
would do like a toy you forget to get
the knife and they would cover it up and
these may be no more than three inches
because it takes three inches of three
pounds of pressure and three inches of
knife will kill you anything below that
one so two and a half inches won't 2
inches won't inch and a half 1
but once you get three and up let's kill
you
cuz it only takes three pounds of
pressure and three inches of steel to
kill an individual you know a soul maybe
they might shoot fire dudes each knife
and everybody guys like an inch and a
half me on the type and you draw all
stab wounds ass you know that's more of
a chicken instead of skin his face or
snaky invisible knife rather stab a
man's ass that way every time he goes to
sit down oh you know I mean he's knowing
[ __ ] did that you know it's really not
visible yeah I'm sad the man has asked
like four different occasions you know
and his friend of mine you know but I
asked to stab him in his ass because
they wanted him stabbed fifteen times
you know they shoot you in order like
okay I want you to stab the guy 20 times
all visible visible
no they won't visit all means with
closures they want to see the holes in
this guy okay when you're telling you to
have the guard 20 times making visible
but you don't want to get that's I can't
promise that I can't you know when you
work when you work for the mob you know
you decide to take that that's dead you
have to remember that there are some
things they're gonna ask dad you're not
just capable of doing there's times they
asked me to do certain things in my
answer was no I know like we need no no
I'm not that's not me that's not my bowl
of [ __ ] wax you mean I don't know
robbed stores
I don't rob people no could go talk to
him and let them know you know they
gotta send money and okay I can do that
but I'm not the type of individual get a
gun and robbed a liquor store that's not
in me I can't rob you on a street corner
that's not in me but now I can gold
someone else and keep playing watch the
door while he does the deed I can do
that you know I can go find somebody I
can go take somebody's win but I'm just
not the side vendor will give me your
money and it's not me
That's not me I wasn't I wasn't made for
that you know I wasn't cut I'm not that
cut from that type of cloth I'm more or
less covering sackcloth where for
instance when I was a youngster you know
I've never been jumped ever and I've
been caught 15 dudes catch me but always
because when I caught people I might
have 15 homies with me and catch one
individual and I'll tell them don't run
we're not gonna jump you I'm not gonna
might want me to jump you cuz I was
always the one in charge so I say I'm
not gonna die on the jump deal i'ma [ __ ]
you up you know he's just gonna be me
you 101 don't worry about nobody getting
in don't get in I'm gonna beat this
individual so I whoop his ass boom
everything being send him on his way and
then maybe two weeks later I'd get
caught by him and his homies and they're
gonna jump me and do my stuff with me
say whoa wait a little
not Wayne jumping in you're gonna die
with my homies no problem let me tell
[ __ ] now get busy and that happened like
seven eight times and I tell them users
they tell me what they got jump that's
all I've never been jumbled oh you never
got runs by a game guys yeah I've been
wrong about 30 [ __ ] but because
of the fact what he did in the past came
back to haunt me but in a good way
and dudes like not winning and a jump
you want me I know who you are
he's a [ __ ] cop you know it's
not fair for him with my homies and you
didn't jump me you let me go ahead with
your homie so I'm gonna give you the
same action so a lot of times that is
being bad fell right in front of me
where I thought I was gonna get my ass
beat by like 20 [ __ ] you know
we took one individual to step up and
tell his home he's not smug [ __ ]
right here cat a chance to jump me could
kill me with his homies nah we're gonna
get matching just like he gave me you
know a lot of times they had saved my
life you know a lot of times I beat him
up you know there's like 20 of them I
beat up like five of them and they're
like they want to jump me so bad but
this dude's like third homie that's
running [ __ ] like nah we ain't jumping
this fool man cuz it's food on and his
other homie with vouchers say yeah oh he
did the same to me he caught me but he
didn't jump me what my ass being jumped
me I used to
[ __ ] that's on the day me you
know that was my that was my my
reputation in my hood that I wouldn't
jump on [ __ ] try to run
[ __ ] over to shoot him up for
good nah I'm gonna beat your ass you
know when I want to go head up because
we went through the Santa Fe Boxing Club
before we got to my hood from nine years
old to 12 years old 9 10 11 12
you used to used to have to go to the
boxing club and then once you turned 13
you can get in the hood but that was a
tradition we went through so every one
of my homies went through the Boxing
Club for 3-4 years and the reason it's
four years because if for years you
fight the Hawaiians and then once you
beat one or two the Hawaiians we do the
boxing club alone and get right into the
hood and I was never jumped in I just
walked in my hood I jumped in everybody
else so you know I've never my homies
I've never put their hands on me to get
me in the hood you know I was already
funded hood my dad's from my
neighborhood my brother both my brothers
my sister all my family the only one
that's not as my mother even my
daughters are from my hood yeah I don't
know if you from dead but they're all
from my hood all of them except maybe
two of my cousins that are males and two
they're females but everybody else is
for my good
every cousin every aunt every uncle from
the for my F for my my hood every gang
my game you just [ __ ] Taranto's all my
family they're fun they're all my uncles
all my aunts
yeah my little girls from my hood my 26
year old she lives in East LA where
she's married and she got out the hood
and said she's living her life now
then I got my 23 year old she's in on
Washington with her husband she might
get her life out there and she don't
speak to me she only speaks to her
mother um and then I got my 22 year old
she just got 21 years she got picked up
for three murders and attempted murder
she fought it for three years she ended
up taking 21 years she's in was at
Chowchilla right now she just pretty
started every time well she got six
years credit so she gots to do I think
nine to 18 I'm about to go see her cuz I
got off parole like five years ago so
I'm about to go see her pretty soon I
just got a cure for this little mr.
Meanor [ __ ] I got well she got she
took 21 years I didn't go to court one
time for her when I was a young man my I
seen these two individuals take this
guy's eyes out with a hammer being took
his eyes off with a hammer with the back
of him yeah the clock ticking both his
eyes out yeah I was only 14 15 when they
did that we were all 14 15 I think the
one that kills 13
he killed him on the spot yeah left him
been there with no eyes took his eyes
out you know I've only thrown up one
time we're sitting it back of chuckling
with your Boulevard and my homie removed
some dudes head with a Mossberg shotgun
I - up that time my homies really sick
individual at that time when the most
looseness the entire scene was in
allocating an LA County gang module
where they stabbed you dude and then
when they were trying to cut his body up
and flush him down the toilet but his
torso wouldn't fit this part yeah
already had got a foot down take a foot
both his hands they just couldn't his
torso was too slowly what they do is
they threw him in the trash can and just
willed him to the shower and I looked
inside that trash can
I didn't know he was in I looked at him
and I almost threw some things I heard
and observed the other cane game I did
he stabbed to death killed him and they
try to cut his body up
I say appetite for it but a hunger it's
easier for you to deal with yeah yeah
except somebody man why don't your
buddies like me and you can go stab
somebody and then also not the were done
stabbing on he's still laying right
there [ __ ] bleeding everything I tell
you make some soup man I'm hungry I mean
I was a tough individual we just stabbed
shout this Duty get on the floor in our
cell but we don't took him under the
bunk but he's under their data and I'm
telling you a hook-up assume you know
put some beans and rice in there and
dudes done dead under the boat that type
of [ __ ] that's where your mind just
automatically gets to where it's nothing
else different type of high you know I
see me I figure I figured after the
first time after the first time
everything else is easy the first time
is the hardest you know that was the
hardest for me the first time you know
cuz you know after I did it it did what
I had to do you know I remember my
blankets got pulled off me I don't know
how many days they had been I don't know
how long I had been but I know it was
hot as [ __ ] in that room because my
grandmother pulled blankets off me I was
fully clothed under my blanket standing
she was everything on I've been wearing
the same thing for three days I haven't
showered I had an eight I just laid
there I had been named there for like
almost three days it's like the third
day my grandmother comes in I could hear
who's the blankets back off me
she opens the windows in the room oh my
god I look to the side of that and my
little brother is sitting in the closet
and he's got two pair of shorts on
extensions and he has all the guns like
this in front of the closet lined up in
front of him and he's just thinking at
me and I'm just looking at him and he's
looking at me we're not saying the word
you know my grandmother's like [ __ ] is
going on here you [ __ ] guys wanna go
outside what the [ __ ] did you do you
know I mean she said that I'm like I
mean so she shoves my little brother and
she what the [ __ ] I said I'm little
bird sit in the closet nothing in the
closet just five guns in front of them
you know
because we both knew what we had did out
there so we didn't want to move we don't
want to go outside and one of these
seals me you know we're so scared we're
so young and we did what we did you know
we did something really [ __ ] really
bad you know and you know it was just
the feeling that we don't want to go
outside so my grandmother came in open
the windows and everything maybe
something to eat and she brought us back
to where we were we were at we were so
far gone already we're just I think I
was my little brother was 12 so I was 13
yeah and that's the first time to be
eating outside there's been other types
of eating go outside for a long time and
but my grandmother already knew if we
didn't go outside you know she started
asking questions started finding out
what was what what that got done because
we wouldn't say nothing we just be in
the room and we don't want to go outside
we want nobody come over we're not home
you know we're not here we just wanted
to be away from everybody else because
we knew what we had get out there you
know and it was me and my little brother
we did that force when the agents like
13 all the way to like 17 years old you
know just me and my little brother you
had a brother in there
he caught a murder he went to ye you got
ye life and I caught my kidnaps and gave
me 15 years so I see my little brother
in a long time he took himself and put
himself on the line activists yes we no
longer thought Oh sweetie no you might
oh brother I mean it bugs me hurts me
you know but I cannot speak to him he's
not on the same side of the fence I'm on
you know
and I want to kill my little brother
it's not what's the least I want to do
you know it was bad enough I had to tell
him you know stay the [ __ ] away from me
you not coming around me you know that's
my little brother you know I've been
through [ __ ] with him that I've been to
with nobody you know but I can't speak
to him there's days that I just want to
get up and go find him you know here
dudes tell me about him and Shaitaan I
tell dudes once you know what's up with
them own product
you know women money individuals you
know I mean hate Envy everything runs
hand-in-hand you know I can stab that
man shot I can put a green light on I
put a green light on [ __ ] you
know it hits me so and she had done to
me so many things happen in my life that
now I walk through here any hour of the
day each time of the day and she could I
want because I finally can say that you
know in certain fashions hanging brace
death no I embrace it I'm not I'm not
afraid to die anymore I used to I think
I'm more or less afraid how I'm gonna
die what's gonna happen you know
somebody gonna shoot me gonna run me
over [ __ ] gonna set me up my just
wonder gonna grab my chest and how heart
attack you know I don't know I'm not
welcoming it but you know I can actually
aunty tell you that I embrace death now
you know I don't feel that death is the
last start I thought it's just another
door opening and you know